vous êtes là également pour un
magnifique album as tu t'adaptes elle a
trouvé bien très bien
j'aurais très bien s'appelle la saga des
miss miss france il ya toutes les miss
et avoue en 1957 manic gt miss élégance
avec ton douala c'est miss élégance et
vous oui à gauche a toujours ça de
chapeau à lui requis côté ava gardner un
wagon auriez plus à frank sinatra vous
j'aimerais vraiment attention ici même à
laquelle était mise pas sympa on ne peut
pas dire ça c'est difficile difficile
dans 50 ans s'il y en a une que vous
n'ayez pas je lisais des interviews
locker way celle qui a posé un apport au
même pas si triste
oui j'étais triste il expliqué elle a
dit d alors même moi j'étais pas content
parce que j'aime bien geneviève elle a
dit des trucs qui était à l'arraché dans
la soute l'autre c'est miss bassin pas
banon elle a rétrogradé sur la chaîne
equidia ballon la fois les jambes ce qui
est drôle c'est que l'automne
c'est bon ça
attends attends la main sur la chaîne
equidia
qu'est ce qu'elle va voir courir la
pouliche miss france c'est bon il ya une
police mais je crois qu'elle en a pleuré
et elle commence à courir les mini
source
elle était à longchamp samedi que
devrait miser sur laquelle elle court
elle la vit ce nom mais la pouliche
alors j'ai bien la clé le monde crier
mais c'est tellement elle vous en a fait
voir de toutes les couleurs on voit des
derniers des nouveaux noms qu'elle
voulait non non il fait doux si j'avais
besoin des quatre légendes genève et à
l'esquivé dit gardez toujours votre
rancoeur vous voir j'avais vous abritez
vous perdez la caméra dites-lui sophie
entre eux car ils vont peut-être les
jambes
et un petit nouveau du goût il va des
robots la laque laquelle était mise je
crache dans la soupe alors la raba
sophie sophie encore ben oui si laquelle
et caylus crade celle qui se savaient
pas qu'ils sont épatés par et elodie go
soit mais c'est normal la mouche à la
ferme
alors je lui ai dit écoutez moi je
savoure le p concentrez-vous j'admire
qu'est ce qui vous gêne le plus mareva
galanter qui se fout à poil
linda hardy qui fait de la télé elodie
gossuin qui trait une vache ou sophie
thalmann qui couche avec un jockey faut
déjà qu'elle baisse la tête pour le voir
ouais c'est ça qui vous choque le plus
nombre une fois bien sûr que non pas une
audi maintenant c'est passé de telemann
à l audience c'est pas les mêmes gens du
même genre la même chose
il n'a pas été mis au jour tu me tapes
s'estime miss région paca je crois oui m
et ses collègues comme geneviève qui va
vous succéder à la tête du comité miss
france est arrivé j'en parle d' elodie
gossuin dans c'est fini ça s'est dit
fasciné c'est du passé avant que ça me
rassure faire ça s'écoute et j'en
donnais en même temps oui je sais faire
ça lui suffit à lui suffit bien alors
mais pourquoi tu l'as pas toi parce que
j'en veux pas alors maintenant on l'a de
manger devant j'avais là-bas son deal
with andy pitié ni celle ci étant vous
la méritez auriez vous gêne pour les
mérites numérique samsung et agricoles
le poireau le poireau j'aime bien me
chercher j'ai une amie qui veut faire le
concours des miss france et ce qu'on
peut être miss france et avoir un casier
judiciaire non ça marchera non saison
régulièrement de viège où est-ce qu'on
peut être miss france
le porno avant non ça marche pas non
est-ce qu'on peut être miss france et
est travestie deviers joncour encore
ça ne peut pas être dispensé être pour
la guerre dans le monde
au nom donc elle n'a aucune chance c'est
qui ta copine ouais c'est une fille qui
voulait de puissance mais alors faire un
jeu miss france 86 valérie bègue miss
france 2010 à roland et là un petit peu
plus difficile quand même miss france
1980 81
il y avait le bénin alors bravo
attention petit vous le monde tombeau
acheté le roulement de tambour seul toit
pour achever le tambour celle remontant
à bosser bosser bosser tous les jours
les roulements de tambour 1988 boccolini
c'est vrai ce budget non 88,88 vous avez
droit à une autre réponse je vous serais
obligé pourtant massimo gargia non 88 88
sièges en cours non c'est épisode the
skies 47 88
après la guerre je cache le nombril bah
si brest vu j'ai à te dire qu'ils
restent buzet comme où certains oui
brisebois et s'était mise vrai ce budget
wee aa
d'ailleurs c'est comme dans nous nous
sommes tentés mais c'est à dire que oui
vous vous dites bresse budget parce que
j'aime ici pas ce budget et moi je dit
sylvie bertin cécile bertin vous le
saviez même passé parisien avait mis
enfin une poulette de bresse mois voilà
le bouquin s'appelle la saga miss france
est extraordinaire c'est un livre
magnifique
c'est un livre qu'on devrait tension
jeudi à fait prête attention je suis un
joueur regarde miss france 47 une très
bonne idée de go voyages aller à l'âge
de deux ans avec elle est toujours là
d'ailleurs c'est l'habit de fontenay aux
roses
c'est vrai ça l ont jamais trop
d'émissions osu sinon non franchement
c'est elle qui avait les plus gros ni je
vais te montrer j'ai revu la 4ème du
genre est énervant c'est simple tu te
mettes de niche mais la belle est au
complet selon ses intérêts dans cette
émission j'aime bien oui je viens des
gros nichons pour vous c'est ce festival
garde et thierry quoi le livre je les
aime beaucoup sa femme et enfants pour
qu'ils voient ce qu'ils peuvent faire
dans la vie à la peinture gaston les
cours est sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu